[موسيقى]
كان دونالد ترامب في التجمع الثالث لحملته
خلال ذلك اليوم كجزء من الحمله الاخيره
قبل انتخابات الثلاثاء وخلال خطابه وقعت
حادثه بين الجمهور وبعدها هرعت
الاستخبارات السريه نحو
المسرح لم يتعرض ترامب لاي اذى وسمعت
صرخات تصدر من الجمهور اثناء ابتعادهم
اعتقل رجل من قبل الشرطه وافراد
الاستخبارات السريه وقال بعض الحضور انهم
راوا احد انصار ترامب يقوم اشاره اصدرت
الاستخبارات السريه بيانا تقول فيه السيد
ترامب اخرج من على المسرح من قبل
الاستخبارات السريه المكله بحمايته بعد
وقوع حاله من الفوضى في الجمهور امام
المسرح مباشره وصرخ شخص مجهول الهويه
قائلا مسدس وبعد تفتيش شامل للشخص
والمنطقه المحيطه به لم يعثر على اي سلاح
وبعد لحظات عاد ترامب الى المسرح لينهي
[موسيقى]
خطابه
وفي بيان له شكر ترامب الاستخبارات
السيريه والجهات الامنيه المحليه والتابعه
للولايه